Antoine fait partie des premiers clients
de ce drive laitier vendredi dernier il
venait chercher ses produits laitiers
sur ce bord de route après avoir passé
commande sur le site internet de la
ferme de Grignon cette ferme
expérimentale tant ici une initiative
originale à portée des produits frais
directement à leurs clients ce camion
frigorifique s'est installé au
croisement des routes départementales en
contrebas de la ferme on s'est rendu
compte que il y avait plus de 26 000
voitures qui passaient devant l'affaire
et qui s'arrêtait pas forcément à notre
boutique on s'est rendu compte que
souvent les gens sont sur des trajets
domiciles travaillent ils rentrent chez
eux ils ont pas forcément le temps de
venir dans l'affaire de s'arrêter
d'aller voir la boutique de faire la
queue et souvent il y a des enfants dans
la voiture sortir les enfants ça prend
du temps voilà donc on a voulu faire un
service offrir un service à ces gens là
pour que ce soit plus rapide pour cette
première en France une vingtaine de
personnes a passé commande les produits
phares yaourt et faisselle les
livraisons s'effectuent pour le moment
tous les vendredis de 16h à 20h si le
concept fonctionne les points de
livraison pourraient se multiplier et
l'offre s'élargir des bières artisanales
au caisseldani